ho ho ho and welcome to gaben Max's
102nd holiday movie preview I love the
holiday season and some of my favorite
too he's from growing up are waking up
on Christmas Eve having a hot glass of
soda and just watching films the film
that Max and I are most excited about
this year is it's complicated oh my god
I'm excited this is the new divorce
comedy from Nancy Meyers and she is just
back with a whole new divorce cast some
of them are divorced and some of them
are just friends right but I think
because that's why we can all relate to
it well I really did because my parents
are divorced and I relate to it because
I'm Gabe's friend and I'm basically the
movie what happens is out baldwin and
meryl streep they were married but now
they're not but there's still something
there and then Steve Martin he's like
Steve Martin is an architect who's an
architect but that John Krasinski is
chronic rosinski is her son and he's a
marine he's a Marine but his legs don't
work anymore no way but the Marines are
like we have a new plan technology for
you but it's on our base in space
basically which is a total space base so
like what they're gonna do with him say
to him face what they say to him as they
say we're gonna put your brain your mind
body and I foot tall Steve Meyer and
blue they put your head in a
nine-foot-tall Steve Martin blue body
yes and because the pandorans they don't
want us there but because they're blue
we may have magic rocks I something I
don't know but they will only the only
listened to blue people I don't know she
built on all new cameras Nancy Meyers me
I will see it's complicated anamorphic
3d imax it's very complicated